shirley maclaine was going to be here to
present the Thalberg award to a brother
warren but she's still not done with her
Streisand tribute at the Golden Globes
so this is an exciting award I would
have voted for Warren Beatty for
president and one big reason Vice
President Jack Nicholson ladies and
gentlemen here's Jack
well because of the dignity of the
occasion miss Manning's delicate
condition and the age of the recipient
there will be no sex jokes and I'm very
sorry about that the most amusing thing
I know about Irving Thalberg is that to
prevent him from getting involved in a
picture that they were filming the Marx
Brothers nailed his office door shut
with him in it
this level of intensity has met its
match in Mad Dog Beatty a nickname
earned as an all-star linebacker in his
native Virginia fight resistance
he's a relentless producer he's even
produced this presentation he's seen to
it that all of the seat fillers are
board-certified obstetricians Warren
leaves little the chance this may be why
he's been nominated for an Oscar 14
times as a producer an actor a writer
and a director and he's the only person
in the history of the Academy to be
nominated in the same year in these four
categories and he's done it twice
and bugsy the gangster character that
Warren plays repeats everybody needs a
fresh start once in a while and that's
what so many of Warren's movies are
about Bonnie and Clyde red shampoo
heaven can wait love affair and Bulworth
are about people starting over with an
almost childlike optimism though they're
often in the middle of their lives they
chase their dreams and their dreams
survive as long as they refuse to give
in to a reality of a world that is
geared to crush them they have a vision
of a better life for themselves the
criminals as well as the politicians and
in warrens movies you can tell the two
apart
more than most Lauren's a blood brother
to the characters that he portrays the
criminal the politician the cop or the
working stiff could never change the
world unless they believed that change
was possible and what will be producer
would ever put together anything so
improbable as a motion picture without
the unshakable optimism that tells him
that this time against all the odds and
ample evidence to the contrary he might
be able to make something great but you
know don't listen to me
let's hear some witnesses he's your
homie you feel that it makes you feel
good he's done it by building up great
reservoirs of courage and I think he's
built up those reservoirs himself I
don't think it was born with him he
works so hard he cares more than anyone
he's working on his hands and knees on
the floor writing the script he's
calling the cinematographer he's hiring
the actor he's making sure the actor
that sick is is taken care of I don't
think there's an actor that I know of
that wouldn't jump at the chance to to
work with Warren he's always pushing the
boundary any artist does that they ask
questions they take chances they may
fall flat but they take the chance and
he does it he has enormous courage he
has guts
congratulations I'll never forget the
look on your face when you told me that
you were going to be getting the
Thalberg award and how much it meant to
you and I congratulate you
because of all these wonderful things
and because of what a good friend he has
been to me I am delighted to present the
Irving G Thalberg award to a filmmaker
we almost lost the politics and by and
by my guess all due respects to the late
great Sam Spiegel the handsomest
recipient of this award ever my friend
and colleague the pro Warren Beatty
you know although some might say it's a
little soon to be given this thing to a
guy in his early 40s
I too have known that I was going to get
it particularly this year with all that
it's been very helpful around the house
I must say I must say that you know if
you had your choice and you could say
get the Thal burg Award or you know the
White House I I think I think would
stick with this yeah I must say I don't
want to talk politics here I don't want
to Paul III and I don't want to suggest
some direction that the that the movies
should go into but I think I would like
to if I may pay tribute to the memory of
my my mother Kathleen my father IRA and
to the to the people who nurtured me as
a child in Virginia with my sister
Shirley and and beginning with Stella
Adler and Elia Kazan and to all the
people who worked with me and taught me
you know I came to Hollywood when I was
in my early 20s many of the previous
winners of this award actually taught me
you know Sam Goldwyn was in his uh his
80s god bless him and he treated me like
a grown-up now it's very interesting III
I think that most of the people who are
teaching right now they all seem to be
in their early 20s and I like I do
whatever I can to keep him I try to get
him to stop treating me like a grown-up
but I I thank them I thank them I thank
my profession for giving me freedom and
access the freedom to live a much fuller
life apart from the movies and the
access to get out and get to know the
world then come back
and go back to making movies please
forgive me for not making more of them
I'll try to do better thank you so much
for encouraging my voice in public
affairs please forgive me if I've used
it stridently or in fact not often
enough I'll try to do better to my
fellow actors I would like to say thank
you thank you for making me look good on
first last and always an actor my pride
and that is unbounded please forgive me
for being a producer I'll try to do
better too you can't hear my game let me
tell you this no it's alright alright
the bread okay now to those of you who
may have heard rumor here are their of
my life in Hollywood as a single man the
the poet wrote only solitary men know
the true joy of friendship others have
the family but to a solitary man his
friends are everything so I want to
thank you my friends for leading me
through those days and finally in fact
leading me to a net please forgive me
for making her unavailable to your
movies four times that's four times
I would like to say I'll try to do
better but you and I know that I won't
so let's just say that I'll try to do
less yes
I'll um I'll try to do this she is my
treasure she has given me what I value
most her love and she's given me Kathlyn
and Ben and Isabel and at the moment
this much-anticipated and very loved
unnamed being who could actually join us
any minute right here in the second row
if I don't wrap this up so I cannot
imagine a public circumstance in which
so many affirmations of work and a life
that could converge at one at one time
let me put it another way as a
screenwriter I'd never sit still for it
you know you can't have the husband up
here getting this thing and the and the
wife down the air maybe getting that
thing and then and she's having a baby
at the same time it doesn't work you
have to throw it out you got to pick one
it just they'll never believe it so I
would say to you that don't worry I
don't ever expect another evening like
this to be so full but there are some
things that really aren't going to
change they don't have to change and
please listen to me on this Kathlyn and
Benin Isabel I know you're not in bed
the things that don't have to change for
us are our reliability of friendship the
sanctity of our family and a dignity of
our work thank you very much from way
down here
they tune up next Brad Pitt Kevin Spacey
Mel Gibson in the Oscar for Best
Screenplay